τρματοφύλακα η γιατί όντο σίμουν τργματο φύλακα η ακατινίε τηλ αλλά πραγματικά όταν όταν έκανά
την πρώτη μου νοριμία με το άρμα εσύψωση είναι αυτό έρωτάς που με την πρώτη
μου ματιά πουλέμε λιπό να φαντααστώ των εαυτό μου με κάτι διαφορετικό λικνά είναι και
πολλά τα χρόνια μέσα στο χώρο ναυτό πολλές απογοητεύσεις οι οποίες εγώτιτις έτσι τις δημαιουργούς
απροκλήσεις όπότε ότι δήποτε άλλον άνθρημα να μουα σου πω άλλα θύρματα που μαρέσουν να
πούμε εντάξει αλλά για να το ακολουθοσω εγώ όχισε προσωπικών επίπεδο ο κυριάκος τι στερήθηκε
περισσότερο για να φτάσει σε αυτό το επιπέδοσε προσωπικό επίπεδο δεν εστερήθηκα τίποτε δηλαδή ακούσυχνα
τιθυσής έκαμες είναι καναπαιδιαθυσίες μου πίσις το στα δικέιδεκευτά εφυθικά χρόνια όκι ιτη φίλη μου
ήταν κιαμέ ου ίτιους φίλους που είχα δεκάπέτεται κξι χρονώ αν ήρτά πίσωτριαξιχρονών που την
αλλάδα και είμαστε νδη παραα παρέ τάξι δεν υκένα εναιέύκεινε να μια στο τόσο και
το ράριο να χώρο να πα καπανάκη να ς πούμε πράπα ησπίτι που έμου τοε
κανένας εν είχα τω περιορισμό απλά μέσα μου ελεγκάτι ότι ξες κάτι και πάει στο
γήπεδο κάνεις προπόα οπότε δεν εστερήθηκα και δεν έκαμα θυσίες γιατί έκανε να κάτει το
οποίο ενεγούσταρα κάτι μου μο άρεσε διασκέθαζα το μέστο χώρο του πλασηστικού αθεμέτω στο χρον
των κυβέδο ν ας πούμεν μπορώ να πό ότε εστερήθηκα κάτι αντιθέτους απόόλαυσα τόσα ωραία
πράματα τός από λατάξθια που σίουρα εντιταξίθκε αναψυχής ή θα πράματα τα οποία αλλο πέντες
ζωές να έκανονα ίσως να μεντε κατάθερνα